when you have to go do kind of the
classic head hunting LinkedIn Twitter
what platform is the most effective it's
not Twitter I can tell you really I met
a Founder the other day he had someone
coming in for a meeting and he said how
should I evaluate this candidate and
they said before you even start asking
them all of the typical questions you
ask a sales leader ask them where they
were born ask them how they grew up what
makes a great recruiter is at the end of
the day
um curious we ask a lot of questions I
like to understand why people are the
way that they are at the end of the day
it's really professional matchmaking all
right guys bang bang I've got Nicolette
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start would be the recruiting Market
is one of these things where when
companies are flushed with cash they
gotta hire people so I'm assuming
business is good when the market goes
down companies get a little bit more
stingy but they still need to hire
people so what goes on in the recruiting
Market when we hit recessions or bad
times stuff like that like how does the
market change
that's a great question so
the good news is is even the most
conservative investors believe that
Talent is a company's greatest asset and
so what you find what you found in June
right when the market started resetting
is people took a really deep look at
what was happening within their
companies and fast forward we've seen
how companies are resetting their
businesses today in the world of
executive recruiting it was taking a
really hard look in the mirror and
seeing what was acceptable with your
leadership team and what needed to be
replaced with your leadership team and
so right now I'd say the past quarter
we've been doing a lot of these
replacement searches bringing on new
leaders that are better for today's
environment than the environment of 2021
when everything was up up and so that's
one part of it the second part is
there's still 600 billion dollars of
capital sitting within investors that
needs to be deployed and we're starting
to see that be deployed right now and we
will will continue to see it over the
next several years so there's also a
significant amount of companies that did
not need to reset valuations that did
not need to do layoffs that did grow
incredibly
smart that are still hiring at the same
Pace that they were prior to this but
you just don't hear about those as much
in the news as you do some of the
companies who are doing layoffs and
resetting valuations today so it's it's
kind of two camps of it right now
um fortunately even in recessions like
recession-proof companies need talent
and they need to grow so you mentioned
this like the team for the environment
and people have uh heard quite often
this idea of like a peacetime CEO a
wartime CEO uh sometimes those can be
the same person sometimes they're not uh
but we always focus on the CEO what
you're really highlighting is like well
maybe there's an executive team that is
set up for good times but they actually
suck during the bad times uh and other
times there's companies that have
executive teams that can do both when
you do the replacement search like how
urgent is it is this a thing where it's
like we just got rid of somebody we need
somebody back in this role in you know
30 days or are they usually saying hey
we got rid of a role maybe it's not so
much because of the person it's more so
because we don't need that role right
now given what we're doing as a business
or the market and so we've got some time
but let's start it and try to find the
right person because diverse says the
bulk of the work we do is with emerging
growth companies the majority of our
searches are company series B series C
stage it's always our job so
that answer is just it's always urgent
and executive Search isn't an overnight
thing it's also not really a 30-day
thing it really on average takes 90 to
120 days because the people that
Founders CEOs boards want to bring on to
these teams to these growing businesses
are in amazing jobs they're not actively
looking they're being compensated well
they're super happy and their heads down
working really hard and so it takes a
few months to recruit a great executive
and so that just adds to the urgency
because oftentimes Founders boards CEOs
know okay this is going to take the next
several months
I need to get started right now or
actually I probably should have gotten
started a month ago and that's often
what we hear when someone comes to us
ready to go on a search and we say you
know what's the level of urgency like
where are you guys and they're like we
should have started this couple months
ago because we now realize how long this
is going to take so for most of the
candidates that you're placing in these
executive roles are these candidates
that you all already have some
relationship with like you've almost
been like pre-veting trying to
understand who the best talent is
establish a relationship and then you're
like hey I'll come to you if I ever have
an open role or these people that when
you're trying to fill an executive role
this the first time you're talking to
some of these candidates and you're
basically saying like hey I know we
don't know each other but there's this
great role you know are you interested
in potentially looking at it it's a
combination of both and so anyone
looking to hire a search firm should for
sure evaluate their Network and get an
understanding of the searches they've
done in the past who they've hired to
show their reach and their scale
um but we're also Headhunters like I I
use that old school term really often
like our job job is to go figure out who
the best people are for a company based
on a variety of different parameters and
regardless if we know them or we don't
know them we're going to go get them so
I've been doing this for a decade and
I'd say of the hundreds of searches I've
done probably half of the people I've
placed new diversa before we made that
phone call and the other half didn't and
that really is a testament to just like
our style and our approach and our
process so it's a combination when you
have to go do kind of the classic head
hunting LinkedIn Twitter what platform
is the most effective it's not Twitter I
can tell you really I have a theory
Twitter is what LinkedIn should have
been it is lethal from a networking
standpoint if you know how to use it
correctly if you know how to use a crack
okay there you go so well maybe with the
new ownership of Twitter Twitter will
become the next great executive surge uh
platform but it's definitely not my
go-to right now so LinkedIn LinkedIn for
sure um we obviously have an internal
database that we use and so we use that
we use LinkedIn and then we use our
Network in the sense of just picking up
the phone and asking people hey here's
what I'm working on
um who do you know for this who should I
talk to because then you also know that
this is someone who you know in your
network that you trust and if they're
speaking highly of someone else and
that's how a network builds it's really
starting with who you know and who's
great at what they do and asking their
opinion on who else they think is great
so it's a combination of all of those
things I mean there's also certain times
where many amazing people actually don't
have a LinkedIn and so you go on to
companies websites you use it the modern
version of Yellow Pages which is Google
and you try to find people's contact
info and you try to build relationships
with them the old school way too so it's
a combination of all those things when
you all are talking internally and
somebody's like oh they're great to work
with meaning a corporation that is a
partner with you all and you're doing
searches for them what are the things
things that make them great and then
vice versa without using names if
there's somebody if you're like ah you
know maybe we won't work with them again
what are the things that they're doing
that put them in that category and how
do you all think about like what makes a
good partner and what does make a good
partner as you're trying to help them
ultimately fill a role that they have
open yes so
trust transparency and communication
that is what makes a great
um search partner so what do I mean by
that it is going into the relationship
knowing that your search partner has the
best interest for the company they're
not looking for just a quick fill of a
role why well we really care about
building long-term relationships because
we work with companies that are emerging
growth so seed series a b c pre-ipo
um
we hope that this isn't the first search
that we do with you we want to build a
long-term relationship we want to be
there for you when you are doing your
first executive hires at series a and
then the next round at series C or when
you're going through an exit so we want
to build a long-term relationship and so
I think knowing most Founders that we
work with most of them this is their
first company that they're building we
have not built companies but we have
built hundreds of leadership teams and
so there needs to be this element of
trust with it it is not a transactional
relationship so communication your
search partner should communicate what a
great process should look like it should
not be a hey just trust us this person's
amazing they should be able to walk you
through a really thorough process that
you as the client feel really good about
knowing okay the search firm is vetting
them they're doing their references and
we're vetting them through a thorough
process but there is an element of
sometimes saying Hey listen you need to
move forward you're going to lose this
person like you need to make them an
offer and we will we people pay us for
our opinion too like we have a very
intimate deep
perspective of the market because of our
Network and so there does need to be an
element of over communicating both on
the client on the search partner side
and on the client side and on the client
side you need to share the information
of the company with us you know
oftentimes
we have clients pitch us as if we
weren't investors in the companies
because what the reason is is I know
what every candidate is going to say
when I call them about this company I
know every reason why they're going to
say I'm not interested thanks I'm in a
great job so I need to get ahead of
those things and so we poke a lot of
holes in businesses to really understand
why is this Recession Proof are you guys
burning cash
um when are you going to have to raise
again because we need to be able to
bring Comfort to candidates that know
this is a startup that's really going to
make it how sophisticated are the
candidates in underwriting that stuff
I'm assuming the best executives are
lethal in terms of their ability to
underwrite these companies they are and
because of the current state of the
market they're way more sophisticated
than they ever have been before so
candidates now are really evaluating
businesses as if they were investors in
the company so every search that we're
starting now and have been over the past
quarter and we've kind of been like this
always but even with a different level
of scrutiny is hey client you need to be
prepared to have the conversation with
candidates the financial conversation
day one not that used to be like the
last step in the process is like okay
let me show you our cap table let me
show you our cash burn let me show you
our bank statements like let me show you
the that don't worry this is okay that
happens very early in the process now
and so communication trust like we are
going to always set up our clients for
success and that is one of the things
we're telling people now it makes sense
that right from a candidate's
perspective I have a friend who um he
end up starting a company but uh the
three companies he worked at beforehand
all went from like seed stage to like
home runs I remember being like hey man
like you should be an investor like
you're pretty good at picking these
things he's like no I have been an
investor I was like what do you mean he
goes I'm about to make an investment of
my most valuable resource which is my
time and so of course that's how I
underwrite it as an investor and it just
like changed the way I thought about
this uh so it makes sense that
candidates especially the executive
level who were supposed to be Educators
you're supposed to understand how these
businesses work would underwrite it in
that way because they not only have
their time but especially if they're
well known or good at their jobs their
reputation at their time to some of
these companies as well and that can
either further your career or it could
potentially put kind of a step backwards
that they then have to go and kind of
recover from yep and that's so that's
the science side of it but then there
was the art element okay and that's
culture and finding the right culture
fit and so we spend a lot of time up
front really understanding the person at
the end of the day I met a Founder the
other day he had someone coming in for a
meeting before he had gone retained with
us and he said how should I evaluate
this candidate and I said before you
even start asking them you know the
sales partners that they brought on
board how they think about hiring a
great sales team all of the typical
questions you ask a sales leader ask
them where they were born ask them how
they grew up ask them about some of the
challenges that they've overcome in
their life as an individual what makes
them who they are as a person because
when you're 10 people in a room 20
people in a room 50 people in a room
culture is as important as skill set is
when you're growing a company in your
early days I think it's important always
but especially in the earlier days of
the company's life cycle and so this
comes back to the communication tell me
who you are as a person hey founder why
are you the way that you are and so we
spend a lot of time really understanding
the person and the mission and why they
started this company what their goals
are long term short term long term
because we obviously also want to be
able to sell it better than they can in
Market do you ever see red flags do you
ever like talk to a founder and you're
like we thought that this was going to
be a great opportunity because of press
or anything like that but then you all
meet the founder and you're like this
may not be as easy as a cell or like we
may not be aligned in terms of sending
candidates that we think highly of to
these companies yeah definitely I think
it comes back to those three things
trust transparency and communication if
I have a client who wants this person
who's I can tell you is not the right
person for what they need and we can't
have a healthy dialogue and I can't show
them Hey listen I hear you I understand
why you want the
VP of engineering at Google but you're a
10 person company and today you probably
need someone who's been in a company
that has built like if we can't have a
healthy dialogue and you know our goal
is to get what our Founders want but we
also spent a lot of time helping Define
what the right thing for the company
right what the right who the right
person for the company is and so there
has to be an element of partnership like
this is your search partner it has to be
a partnership and if we feel like
there's no partnership at the end of the
day then we're not going to be able to
successfully close and there's give and
take on both sides right every search we
do is incredibly challenging that's why
we exist because it's super hard we
recruit the one percent of of Executives
in the world
um so it's not easy but there has to be
an element of partnership to it in order
for it to be successful are there
elements of a 10 person company that
could make the VP at some large
corporation uh or somebody who's very
high up leave and actually join the 10
company that you've seen
yeah
I think that really comes out what is
the secret I think it's personal passion
and this goes back to you know if you're
gonna join something that early my guess
is they're not turning a profit they
have a lot of work to do but if someone
if there is someone who is so burningly
passionate about what this company is
doing and that kind of goes back to like
the art side like there's a culture
element that is so important to that
person that they have to be a part of
this Mission solving this problem
because probably ties back to something
that happened in that person's life that
probably would be the thing that does it
but I also still don't know if that
person's right for that company right
like that person is managing a lot of
people they're not the one writing code
today so that's where we go back to Sure
even if you could get that person does
that necessarily mean they're the right
person for you today and we've seen it
happen we've done it but it's it's
really about let's define what the
problem is that needs to be solved today
and then who's the right person to solve
today's problem because that's also
really different than the person who's
gonna solve the problem two years from
now so one of the things I see Founders
make mistake over and over and over
again is exactly what you're talking
about here where uh they have a company
it is promising it's working it's headed
in the right direction and they're like
if only we can hire this person and it's
always somebody who is uh two to three
stages further along than what they
probably need uh and I always say like
the risk in that is that person is used
to managing people not doing the work
right
um but when those opportunities pop up
how do you all talk to the company about
uh do you pass on the person do you try
to hire them as like a maybe a advisor
or something and then eventually bring
them on full time like how do you kind
of navigate where they're actually maybe
interest from both the candidate and the
company and each other
but do you all take an opinion as to
like maybe this isn't actually the right
time for you all to do this oh 100 and
this goes back to like people pay us for
our opinions as well on the market so my
when that happens and it happens all the
time I say why why do you want that
person because oftentimes I don't think
um when you're building a company and
I'm not a Founder so there's a lot of
things I don't know about building a
company but what I do know is what
someone's skill set is and so I often
say why
um why do you think that that's the
right person for you right now and I
often find that they don't actually
realize what that person's day-to-day
job is and that goes back to your point
of they're sitting in board meetings
they're talking to investors they're
managing thousands of people you have a
10 person 20 person 30 person company
what you want is someone on that
person's team or someone who worked for
them in a past life someone who they
have mentored and trained because likely
the person that they're pointing to is
truly the best in the entire world but
at one point they weren't and so they
grew and they grew other people and they
built and they so you want that person
10 years ago so we want to go find who
five years ago you want to go find who
that person is today who becomes that
person for you as the company grows and
so it's again it goes back to that
dialogue that transparency that
communication and kind of working
backwards to unpack what's the problem
who's the right person to solve it how
much does money enter into the
conversation when you're trying to
recruit you know the big hire right uh
if you're a startup you just raise 20
million dollars everyone thinks that
you're the greatest thing ever uh and
you go to a Canon and you're like I'll
just pay 5 million bucks cash come work
here does that move the needle for a lot
of these candidates or is it something
that they're willing to uh say hey it's
important but it might not be the most
important thing and so I will take it
into consideration but actually let me
look at these other things like how do
you see candidates reacting to really
big almost egregious offers from the
employment side well I can tell you that
in the 10 years that I've been doing
this I don't think I've ever seen a 20
million dollar company write a five
million dollar check for a candidate and
I actually have multiple times even for
you know people ask us for guidance on
how do I get this person what's the
right offer there are many times that
I've said listen I love it I love that
you're willing to do this but this is
probably not a good idea like you should
prob if you only have 20 million dollars
raised you should definitely not be
spending five million dollars in cash to
get someone you should go get the right
person you should want to give them
Equity that person should want to be
bought into the business at this size
and stage but yeah offers make a huge
impact in what you're willing to do and
we are always guiding clients on here's
what it will take to get this person
here's what you need to be willing to do
and that often goes back to kind of
resetting expectations hey you want the
chief product officer of LinkedIn well
you're not we can't afford them right
now and again going back to why they're
not right for you
um but we always kind of set
expectations day one on here's what you
need to expect to pay acfo here's what
you need to expect to pay a chief
marketing officer or VP of marketing
both from a base bonus and an equity
perspective so we have a lot of those
benchmarks that we're able to share so
we can make sure we're all aligned
because the other thing trust
transparency communication is alignment
you got to leave that meeting day one
knowing we are all on the same page
we're all working towards the same thing
and so you know we call that stuff out
very early as you've seen the market go
up a lot in 2021 down a lot in 2022 what
is changing with comp are people wanting
more money do they understand that
companies might not be willing to invest
this much money in in certain roles like
what's changing
um I would say that comp has always been
a really big factor in a decision it's
not the only Factor but it's a big it's
a big factor
um whereas maybe last year
people were more willing to take bigger
cash hits in return for enormous Equity
people have a much different perspective
on Equity today candidates have always
at offer stage given their own
perspective on what they think a company
is about going back to your point on
they operate as investors you know I've
we've had offers made and we say okay
here's 10x here here's what happens if
we 2x 5x 10x and the clients will go
through that and the candidates like
yeah that's not realistic like I love
this company I'm excited to join it but
I don't believe that the equity is worth
this at 10x so they've always been again
operating as investors but I would say
today because we've seen valuations be
cut so much and we know that the next
round of Investments are going to come
with lower valuations and what we've
seen in Market cash is important people
care about cash today and I know it's
not the five million dollar check but I
don't think as many executives are
willing to take such enormous cache hits
they're all taking cachets most of the
time for the equity because you can't
have everything
um but they're definitely like someone's
Really Got to Believe In the outcome of
the equity and what that story is
um and you know cash plays a big role
today so if I'm an executive at a big
company and I'm like all right I'm just
tired of working in the bureaucratic
environment
um what's the best way for me to go
about finding a job at what I desire in
uh like a fast growing startup like how
do you think about the correct path or
like the optimal path for the candidate
to end up in a great company this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermo regulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
in each sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eatsleep.com pump not only do
I sleep on it every night it literally
changed my life and I begged the
founders to let me invest in the company
hsleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep I would reach out to a company
like diversa right we have such a deep
lens into so many companies who don't
even have Press today but our incredible
companies that if you were just an
executive at a big company you might not
even know exists we also go going back
to like the art side of things culture
like if you're going to come join a
growing company well then let's let
diversa understand who you are as a
person what your skill sets are and we
can help figure out when the right
opportunity comes around that this is
top of like we keep you top of mind for
the right opportunity
um so that would be one thing I would do
and then if you are an executive in a
big company and you have friends in the
Venture Capital space friends in the
private Equity space ask them what
they're seeing like educate yourself on
sectors that are doing really well if
you're if you're passionate about a
certain sector go talk to other people
in that space and kind of just educate
yourself broadly on what companies are
doing who exists what's exciting but I
would definitely lean on your executive
recruiter friends who evaluate companies
all day long and are selective about who
they'll work with and why and we're here
to help you've mentioned culture a few
times I've had experiences uh throughout
my career where uh I think I've come to
the conclusion like there's not good or
bad culture it's more of like is there a
cultural fit where the company and the
candidate both agree that they want to
work in a certain type of culture and
that's why you see some companies uh
employees like this greatest place I've
ever worked and other people are like
this place sucks and I can't wait to
leave how do you all think about
evaluating the culture and then also in
some ways you have to then turn around
and be like a cultural
salesperson to then go sell the
candidate I'm like this is the culture
you're looking for this is a culture
where you'll be productive and kind of
accomplish things you want in your
career yeah and so that goes back to how
much time we spend up front with
Founders and teams right we go into
their offices we spend hours there we
kind of put like a McKinsey hat on and
we integrate ourselves into these
companies and we spend a lot of time
with people and I'd like to think at
this point we're really good at reading
people and understanding people so as
much as we go deep on a company and
understand why they're going to be
successful why they're recession-proof
what the growth plans are et cetera we
spend a lot of time on people values how
they operate day to day how often
they're in the office how all of the
elements that come into a culture aspect
we evaluate the same way as we do as the
mechanics of the business and so then as
we're selling that in market like we're
able to put our story together on it
um both inclusive of the business
mechanics and the culture aspect so I'm
a company and let's say I want to hire
or a CFO a CMO kind of one of these
executive roles what should I do like
what makes me uh effective in using a
firm like you all but also what should I
be doing either before or during that
process to make sure I get the best
candidate possible yeah so one of the
things that I often tell Founders and
CEOs is think about if you're a Growth
Company think about what the what the
main objectives are of the business over
the next two years don't forecast past
that when you're thinking about a role
and sure you can argue a day here and
there but growing companies their needs
change very often CFO specifically it's
very common that you'll do a CFO search
day you know series a another one at
series C and another one through an exit
like you need to anticipate you'll
probably have a couple of them sure be
great if someone grows into that and if
not that's okay you probably need a
different person who has raised hundreds
of millions of dollars who has taken a
company through an exit before and that
person's really different than your
person at series a and so I would walk
through one the mechanics of the
business if we're talking CFO a SAS CFO
is really different than a consumer
goods CFO they just they focus on
different margins and they have
different relationships one needs to
also understand how to work with supply
chain and vendors and another one
doesn't so understanding the mechanics
of your business day one what the goals
are over the next few years and then
working backwards and scoping out here
here's what I need this person to do
over the next two years and that's where
your search partner can say Okay based
on that here's where we think this
person should come from here's the
different types of profiles we should
look at so that's a place I would start
whether it's
have to fundraise or I have to become
profitable or I really need a strategic
business partner who knows how to
increase our margins from an e-commerce
perspective whatever it may be and it's
oftentimes a combination of a lot of
those things figure out what the problem
is and work backwards to solve it and
that's how you should really build a
jobs back and that's how a search
partner should advise you on what you
should need in that process
um how big is like the top of funnel
right so I'm trying to fill let's say
CFO role am I going to talk to 25
candidates am I going to talk to five
candidates am I going to talk to 100
candidates like what do you see
obviously understand there's outliers
like what is like the average process
kind of filtering the first round has
this many people and then how many kind
of make it to the final stage yeah so
when we scope out the job at hand and
just go and you include culture include
location you include
every element of what this company needs
at the end of the day there's probably
only 10 people out there who can do this
job and who are right for this job and
our goal is to go get those 10 people in
front of you but then you run into
things like sorry I can't relocate my
family to that location or I have
20 million dollars vesting over the next
two years like I'm not going anywhere
for whatever reason I'm not passionate
about that to go back that early and
build again that's not what it's going
to take to do it so the list gets short
really fast and our job on like an
average search I would say a good search
a client should meet five to ten people
and so we're much more quality over
quantity focus and this comes back to
the trust element on our end we're going
to talk to more people than that we're
going to talk to 20 30 40 people for a
job sometimes even more than that but
our goal is to get the best five to ten
in front of a client
remote versus in person uh you mentioned
not relocating there's some people who
are like that sounds insane people still
do that and there's other people who are
like yeah of course like we're all going
to go back to the office there's gonna
be no such thing as remote what are you
all seeing in terms of the the
importance that companies placing on it
and then the importance that the
candidates are placing on it I have
wanted an easy answer to this question
for two years and it just made me
frustrated that I still don't have a
great answer to it and that's the
reality if you're like what's the trend
the trend is it's literally all over the
place like I am seeing startups
um back in office I am seeing startups
work from home I'm seeing public
companies back in office public
companies in home and then a combination
of it all so it is all over the place
my opinion is if you are a growing
company in the early days there are so
many elements that are very important to
be in an office together and it doesn't
have to be five days a week I do think
that the probably the right answer
somewhere there is a hybrid model but a
a few days a week in an office together
reason being is if you're building a
company your engineering team needs to
understand what your operations team is
doing and vice versa and your marketing
team needs to be able to walk over to
the tech team and say okay if we're
going to position this in Market I need
to understand what we're building and
how do I translate that into a
consumer's mind so I just feel like it's
a lot easier and more efficient to be in
an office together building
I also see the element of which by the
way that makes my job harder but I still
feel like that's probably the right
thing to do there is an element of well
if I can have access to that talent that
I never would have been able to have
access to because I knew they can't move
and I'm willing to take the bet on them
because they're so good at what they do
that I know they can do this remote
that's a win as well too like people are
getting access to talent that they've
never had access to before because we
have worked in a much more remote world
over the past couple years I still think
that we're
five to ten years away from seeing what
the right answer was right companies
take about 10 years to you know to to
build into big businesses and so I think
in the next five to ten years we'll be
able to look back and say wow here's a
winner who did it fully remote I guess
as possible or we'll be able to say wow
here's a company that failed and they
were remote so that's not the right
answer or we'll have a broader pool of
data that kind of says what the right
answer is and maybe it's based on sector
maybe it's based on geography whatever
it is I just I don't think we're there
yet but it's all over the place and
we're doing plenty of searches that are
fully remote plenty of searches that I
need this person in this location what
other Trends are you seeing that people
are interested in obviously there's like
the investment Trend so uh Bitcoin
cryptocurrencies gets very popular now
like uh generative art and artificial
intelligence and all that's popular uh
there's like American dynamism is
another Trend that kind of jumps to mind
there's probably many others that are
out there what are you seeing from like
the candidate side that they're actually
interested in a lot of those that you
just covered people really do care about
making the world a better place like as
however it sounds dumb but it is real it
is a real thing yes as cheesy as that
sentence sounds it is a real thing like
people want to do if they're when I say
people I'm obviously talking about the
the hard charging one percent of
Executives out there like they work
incredibly hard incredibly efficient
they want to wake up every day saying I
am so glad that this is where I'm
deploying my time
um and so a lot of the topics that you
talked about are big ones web three
despite everything that's happening
right now people are still excited about
it
um
Frontier Tech energy I think energy and
climate are going to be really big over
the next several years as we're seeing
everything and how that affects our
broader Global markets and how much
opportunity maybe there is for companies
to make that whole process much more
efficient as complicated as it is and
well above my skis
um so Healthcare that's another really
really big Trend right now that
candidates are excited about because at
least here in the US there are still so
many elements of our Health Care system
that are fragmented that are broken that
really need modernization to them and so
those are really big markets and Trends
right now that we're seeing so we've
talked about like what I'll call
industry Trends we've talked about uh
candidate Trends we've also talked about
building these teams around the CEO or
founder what about we had to replace the
CEO like you and I have talked before
about sometimes literally a board or a
company just says we're changing
complete paths or the CEO quit right
it's something that I've seen a couple
of times like what happens in that
scenario because it's almost like who do
you partner with at that point like who
who are you actually pitching the
potential new CEO on working for or with
it's mostly the board well it's pretty
much always the board
um board main investors chairman whoever
really owns the company at that point is
the one that we're working with in those
scenarios I feel like it's much less the
CEO quit and it's much more the this is
no longer the right person for this
company and when you're doing a CEO
search like is there anything that's
different than if you're doing a CFO or
CMO search or uh is it all pretty much
you're looking for an executive and so a
lot of same qualities exist it's just
often more decision makers because if
you have a five-person board versus
ultimately at the end of the day the CEO
is they're hiring a chief marketing
officer CFO yes there's other
stakeholders yes you want the rest of
the leadership team to be excited about
them yeah sometimes you ask a board
member for advice and opinions and you
want their green light it's really the
CEO who is making the hire for their
leadership team at the end of the day
when you have a board you have a handful
of people who maybe come from all
different types of backgrounds and
perspectives and they need to agree on
one person like the most critical person
in a company so it just becomes a bit of
a longer process more Cooks in the
kitchen different level of
scrutiny and evaluation that goes into
it it's not too dissimilar it's just
more people to make to agree upon a
decision
diversa is an interesting company you
all have hundreds of employees I I
believe and you do retain search not
contingency uh describe the difference
between retained and contingency like
what the pros and cons of each are so a
contingency search is when a company
goes to a contingency firm and they say
hey we are looking for a marketing
director or a VP of marketing
please send over some resumes and that's
much more of like we're sending over
vetted resumes of people that are much
more passively looking or actively
looking whereas on the retained side we
are hired by the clients we're not hired
by our candidates we're hired by the
clients whereas like contingency to me
also feels a little bit more they're
working for the candidates and there's
like a candidate element of contingency
too where you are
working on behalf of a candidate to help
them find a job which is there's a big
candidate element in the work that we do
but at the end of the day we're hired by
a client who says I need a VP of
engineering can we are going to hire you
to fill this so with us it's also we're
in the search until the search is closed
there's no time limit on it as well too
on average they take a couple months but
if it takes six months we're in the
search till the search closes like
retaining a lawyer for something so that
is the model and I also think you know
when you're a Services business you're
only as good as your last search and so
our goal is to of course efficiently
close it within a certain time period
but we need the right person because we
also will have to redo the search if
it's not the right person we care much
more about building relationships it's
less transactional so depending on the
role
is how you kind of decide which one's
the best one for you there's plenty of
amazing contingency firms too it's just
a different model uh let's talk
individual examples like are there one
or two examples that you have where
people have actually left companies and
then kind of gone through this process
and we can maybe use them as as the
example to to kind of talk through this
left their current companies to join a
Growth Company yes so there's a so many
examples of this
um I think if we're talking about just
the evolution of the web 3 space You
know open C just brought in Brian
Roberts who was the CFO of Lyft saw them
through tremendous scale through an exit
they brought him on board as CFO right
and then we were also seeing someone
like pranesh who was the VP of
engineering a VP of um HR over at Uber
come join Kraken to be their Chief
people officer and so you're seeing
these tremendously successful execs who
what's interesting weren't just at Lyft
and Uber when they were massive
companies but they were there through a
lot of the early days a lot of the scale
a lot of the transformation and change
of those businesses
um overcame and then they both went and
joined massive exchanges in the web 3
space so while it's possible to do it
across so many sectors I think a lot of
people right now feel like that's a very
challenging one and is it possible to
still get great talent to come join and
the answer is yes like why do you think
they did it do you think it's because
they were like so inspired by the
mission of the company they ended up at
was it a huge pay package is it a
combination of things
I think at the end of the day people
have this Miss
conception about will web 3 make it like
it is all the technology like the
underlying blockchain technology and all
the Technologies of these companies were
already out of the proof of concept
phase like these are working and just
because the market is down right now
just because these will overcome a lot
of regulatory challenges doesn't mean
they're not going to exist and this is
what I keep going back to the example of
what
um kind of Health Tech was 10 years ago
is very similar it was new there were
regulatory elements that came with it
but it didn't stop all these amazing
Executives from saying I want to be a
part of the next Frontier of what our
health care System should be I and all
these execs are saying I want to be a
part of the next Frontier of what the
internet and what our experiences what
currencies are going to be like this is
the future and we're in it right now and
these guys want guys gals they want to
be a part of it they're willing to take
the risk you know both of those examples
just happen to come from ride-sharing
companies you think 10 years ago people
were like this is gonna work like this
makes sense let's revolutionize taxis
like I can't even imagine the amount of
you know people who thought that that
was ridiculous but they did it and I
think these come from high-powered
really thoughtful smart Risk Takers and
again it's out of the proof of concept
phase it's working and so it just
require is these exacts to build it who
have patience who have been through hard
building businesses before and yeah I'm
sure there's a lot of other reasons that
they took the job at the end of the day
but there's a big piece of it it's a big
piece of it
um what about people who listen to this
or watch it and they're like I want to
go work at diversa like like what are
the types of people who become great
recruiters themselves
um most of us did not think we would be
recruiters one day like no none of us
went to college at most of us that said
I want to be an executive recruiter I
didn't even know this was a job a lot of
us had Communications backgrounds or
business backgrounds
um and I think what makes a great
recruiter is at the end of the day
um curious we ask a lot of questions
um I wanted to I'll just use myself and
speak on behalf of myself I was a
journalism and Communications major I
thought I was going to go be in
broadcast journalism and I decided not
to take that route and I didn't really
know exactly what I wanted to do came
across executive recruiting what I found
from that is I liked talking to people I
love talking to people I'm a naturally
curious person I'm asking a lot of
questions on both behalf of the
businesses and candidates that I work
with I under I like to understand why
people are the way that they are at the
end of the day it's really professional
matchmaking and so I think if you're
someone who is naturally curious who
likes learning new things there's a
there is a sales element to what we do
we have to sell candidates on
opportunities and sell clients on the
fact that this could be a great fit for
you this is a great candidate so it has
a lot of really interesting business
elements you know things that investors
think about things that sales leaders
think about things that people leaders
think about kind of all Blended together
and if those are things that are
exciting and fun for you then recruiting
or executive recruiting is um a great
path for you and then when you talked
earlier about the types of people who uh
you end up getting referred to on the
candidate side you've talked about
referrals on the business side there's
other players in the market there's
investors there's lawyers accountants
those types of organizations do you all
work with them at all uh in terms of
either finding uh potential Partners or
learning about companies or anything
like that we work really closer with
closely with the investor community so a
lot of the VCS a lot of the private
Equity firms we are very very close with
and and again it comes from them saying
hey we just invested in this company
super excited about them but they need a
new VP of HR and we want you guys to
connect with them and give them some
guidance on how they should be thinking
about this and so what we'll often do is
ask the investors
what did you see in the company like why
are you excited about this and it's just
another data point for us
um to think about the good the bad the
ugly right nothing's ever perfect and so
we asked all the good we understand
where the challenges are why they think
they need this role in addition to
hearing it from a Founder it's really
great to get the investors perspective
as well too yeah that makes uh that
makes sense what's your favorite part
and your least favorite part about the
executive search business
wow
well I think my favorite part is just
I love meeting people like I really
enjoy hearing people's stories
um and getting to know why someone is
the way that they are why they work the
way they do why they're motivated the
way they are and I also love the fact
that I get to have like a firsthand look
into new technologies new ways of uh
thinking about Healthcare new ways of
consumer experiences like it's just
fascinating to me
um I feel like we kind of get a front
row seat into things that are going to
happen before they happen before the
rest of the world gets to see them and I
think my favorite part is also the fact
that CEOs and Founders who are building
tremendous companies who have
multi-billion dollar valued businesses
say what do you think I should do about
this and they ask us what they should do
they ask us how they think about these
how they should build their businesses
where they should make a hire these are
really critical decisions that a founder
and CEO has to make and I just think
it's really cool that they ask us how
they should do it
um
you're my least favorite part no be
honest
um
it's really hard like it's really hard
it's a lot of work but you know it's
also kind of fun because that's the
challenge of it I enjoy the challenge of
what we do but it's really hard
um it's not a nine to five job when you
are head hunting it is it is a it has a
24 7 element to it because you have to
think about it a lot of candidates who
are heads down in great jobs they can
talk to you at 9 00 PM they can talk to
you on Sunday you talk to you on
Saturday they're not going to talk to
you within their business hours when
they're having meetings with their boss
and their team so you have to be really
adaptable to other people's schedules as
well too and like sure that there's an
element of that that's that's hard um
and maybe can be some people's least
favorite part but I think the rewards of
what we do and what we get to see and
who we get to meet the teams that we
feel like we get to build like so much
more rewarding than there is anything
that you know we don't there's a reason
I've been doing this for 10 years yeah
well it leads into the last thing I want
to talk about uh you are a new mom I'm a
new dad uh and one of the things that I
think we both probably at least I put
more thought into is like hey I could go
when I could work 12 hours a day or like
you know there's this like little person
uh that I enjoy spending time with as
well and there's a balance and so most
Executives for the most part not always
but most of them are a little bit
further along in their career which
tends to mean that just from an age
perspective they likely are or they have
a higher probability of having a family
uh of having children all the stuff how
does the balance between like work and
life or family or any of that play into
it and has that changed over the last
two or three years because of the
pandemic and people seeing their kids
I've talked to people who are literally
like I didn't realize like I never saw
my kids now I saw them because I was
locked in the house with them yeah and
sure there was like crazy times but like
I enjoyed it and I want to do that more
like what have you all seen there
um as you've talked to candidates I
think I just stay away from like work
life balance it really is integration
today like it is not balanced because
they really don't think it's balanced
but I think it's integration and that's
where I you know I made a stance and how
important it is I think for people to be
in an office but I think that the hybrid
model is a really really good one where
you have time in the office but you also
have time to
um be with your family you have time to
run the errands that you never get to
run you have time to work out you have
time to do the other things that you
need to do to make you the best version
of yourself and I think Executives and
any human
is going to be better at their job if
they're the best version of themselves
and so we now live in a world where
people realize okay if you clocked in at
nine and you clocked out at five like
that actually doesn't matter it doesn't
matter when you clock in clock out if
you're a trusted executive and you prove
that you can do the work and get done
what needs to get done within the
certain time parameters well then do it
however you want do it wherever you want
obviously it has to work for the company
but I I think the benefit of all the you
know past couple years is people realize
that anyone who is really good at their
job who is responsible who works hard
and gets done what needs to get done
shouldn't be micromanaged in a way where
they have to physically be somewhere at
a certain time again I go back to like
yasu needs to be in an office if that's
important to the company but there
should be a way to integrate it less so
balance it because anyone working you
know super hard Around the Clock it
doesn't really feel like a balance some
days
um but I also think
you can have it all but you can't have
it all at the same time some days you're
gonna put more into your job some days
you're going to put more into your
family and some days you're going to put
more into yourself and it's just about
making it all work
it's interesting to say integration
because I do think that uh people now it
used to be like there's the family life
and then there's like the work life and
now like I don't know I don't know what
the percentage increase but like I do
phone calls people all the time and
they're like oh sorry I got my kid here
or this or that like it's almost just
become like more okay uh to have the
integration or like the Lines Blurred
whereas I feel like maybe our parents or
our grandparents generation it was like
I would be so embarrassed there's the
one video the guy who was like doing the
live TV interview and the kid ran in and
he was like freaking out the mom I think
it was like crawled on the floor to try
to grab the kid or whatever and I think
now people just like oh like that's my
kid right and so I Society T wise like
it feels like a net benefit but it also
it does cause change in like the work
environment I also think we have
technology that they didn't have back in
the day like we can take our cell phones
anywhere I can do my job anywhere as
long as I have my phone with me I could
be on vacation and take a candidate call
if I need to because I have my phone
with me and really that's all I need at
the end of the day whereas like
obviously our our parents our
grandparents didn't have that luxury we
can zoom if needed you know if we can't
be in person like we just have the
ability to do things really differently
than Generations previously and I think
that's only going to continue to evolve
and change over time but the candidates
you know on the phone with their kids in
the background that has been our life
forever because again candidates don't
often talk to us when they're at their
office they'll talk to us when they're
driving they're dropping their kids off
at school in the morning or on a weekend
when they've got their In-laws in town
so like we're used to hearing that
background they're using you guys to get
away from the in-laws basically yeah
exactly call us if you need to get away
from your in-laws
um but no we're just you know we're used
to working around other people's
schedules and it's often times when they
are home with their families yeah that
makes sense where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find out
more about diversa yeah
diversapartners.com is where you can
find us you can check us out on LinkedIn
or go to our website
I don't think I've had anyone who ever
said LinkedIn before so I know that you
guys are in the recruiting business
because that's where all the recruiters
are exactly awesome well thank you so
much I appreciate this I really learned
a lot and I think it's interesting uh
kind of the difference between the
contingency uh versus the retained
search but also uh you all specialize in
executive Search and so if folks are
looking for uh filling those types of
roles um you know I tend to give advice
to Founders like go work with people who
are experts at that one thing uh and you
guys definitely are on the executive
Search side so I appreciate it we'll
definitely do it again in the future
awesome thank you so much it's been fun